du week-end dernier y en a pour qui
c'est clair c'est christophe castaner il
l'a redit hier soir et pour lui il faut
pas y aller il était devant l'assemblée
nationale devant le sénat pardon lors
d'une audition
je voudrais profiter de ce moment
d'audience pour avec vous porter un
message essentiel qui est celui de
l'appel au calme et j'invite les gilets
jaunes raisonnable
ceux qui ne soutiennent pas l'action
volante à se désolidariser des extrêmes
et à ne pas se rassembler à paris samedi
prochain alors la question qui se pose
c'est est-ce qu'il faut interdire ce
serait au moins clair cette cette
manifestation je vous cite une phrase de
l'éditorial distraire dans le figaro de
ce matin
rien ne saurait justifier que se
reproduisent les exactions perpétrés
samedi dans plusieurs villes
ni le climat de guerre civile qui
régnait sur paris peut-être yves que la
meilleure façon d'éviter sa basse et de
l'interdire purement et simplement parce
que chacun sait que c'est impossible de
dire que vous interdisez mais il ya
quand même des gens qui convergent
je sais pas n'importe où dans paris peut
pas les empêcher de se promener à oui
c'est impossible la liberté de
circulation existe encore dans notre
pays et c'est là tout le problème si
vous voulez non je crois que là où il ya
une réflexion à mener et c'est là où je
condamne d'ailleurs la ville al
l'ensemble du personnel politique qui
tombe sur le gouvernement en disant vous
avez fait c'est vous qui avez créé la
violence en gros parce que vous êtes
trompé de tactique non la tactique était
peut-être pas la bonne
la tactique de la police pour contenir
les manifestants la tactique était
peut-être pas la bonne sûrement pas la
bonne la preuve c'est que quand même il
ya une merveille après une mort quand
même faut quand même là ajouté elle
était peut-être pas la bonne mais ceux
qui ont créé la violence c'est pas la
présence des forces de l'ordre
évidemment c'est évidemment les gilet
jaune il faut le dire c'est pas
uniquement des casseurs venus de
banlieues des black blocs venu justement
des extrêmes
c'est aussi des casseurs qui emportés
par leur élan et ben s'en prennent à
tous et c'est le propre d'ailleurs de
toute insurrection moins sucré je suis
frappé de la mansuétude avec laquelle on
traite ce ministre de l'intérieur la
voilà un homme qui est en situation
d'échec flagrant et dans toute autre
démocratie que la france il eût été
conspué à son tour et il aurait été
renversée dans un débat parlementaire
normale dans une autre démocratie dans
une autre démocratie que celle de la
vème république partout ailleurs en
europe
cet homme aurait déjà quitté ses
fonctions il ya plusieurs jours non ça
fait rien ce qu'il a fait est très grave
il a totalement sous-estimé l'ampleur de
la manifestation et tout le monde sait
que sur environ un peu moins de 5000
policiers chargés de des forces de
l'ordre de différents corps d'ailleurs
600 ou 700 ont été affectés à
strictement au contrôle et à l'anc à
l'encadrement de la manifestation
l'hérault les autres étaient affectés à
la garde des bâtiments publics tout à
fait nécessaire il était question ça
c'est pour que troisième ça s'est passé
et on samedi prochain qu'est ce qu'il
faut pour être parce qu'au nom de la de
la protection de l'ordre public on
pourrait dire toute personne portant un
gilet jaune sera arrêté par la police
qu'une façon d'interdire l'importation
de voitures mais pas les temps et qu'on
peut pas dire tous forson personne ne
porte un gilet jaune soit interdite ou
arrêtés ou appréhendé parce que c'est
illégal
donc c'est tout à fait naturel dans une
démocratie et dieu merci comme la france
que de sortir du métro de revêtir un
gilet jaune et d'aller dans un lieu de
rassemblement
ça on peut pas l'interdire il n'est pas
question de l'interdire
ce qu'on peut imaginer en revanche c'est
qu' une canalisation des flux humains
beaucoup plus serré et beaucoup plus
organisés que ce qu'elle l'a été je
raisonnais on peut poser la question du
recours à d'autres forces de l'ordre par
exemple que celles habituellement
affectés il ya mon ami un sujet elle
parce que t'as pas être au niveau visuel
sags ont demandé aux militaires de
garder les bâtiments et ils l'ont fait
on peut peut-être demander charger les
militaires de garder les bâtiments et
chargé les déficients juste pour vous
donner la vie des internautes qui sont
d'accord avec vos cris somaca reliant
disons non il ne faut pas interdire la
manifestation
vous êtes 58 % à considérer qu' il ne
faut pas le faire ce serait la pire
décision politique dans ce contexte nous
dit un internaute si je te dis de toute
façon interdite ou non cette
manifestation aura lieu il vous ajouter
quelque chose et après on passe à la
ballon
adam recourir aux militaires si jamais
militaire pour les gardes statiques
autour de l'elysée l'assemblée nationale
si jamais il ya un mouvement de foule
le militaire qu est-ce qui fait il tire
c'est pas si bien sûr c'est qu'on tire
donc là on va se retrouver dans une
situation qui à mon avis c'est une
situation comparable à ce qui s'est
passé pour la guerre d'algérie
donc c'est pas tout à fait squat est
souhaitable la deuxième chose c'est que
là où on peut se réfléchir par exemple
la faute peut-être du ministre de
l'intérieur
c'est de ne pas avoir sanctuariser la
place de l'étoile ça une vraie quand le
quand il nous dit qu'elle a été elle a
été celle à échapper à la police si
celle ci par exemple nous savons que
nous sommes que le on n'a pas donné
ordre aux policiers d'abord de quitter
ou de renoncer à leurs congés et que ce
week end là il avait pris pour la peau
d'une grande partie par d'entre eux
leurs congés alors que des réquisitions
normale dans ce corps auraient pu être
prises afin qu'ils soient présents dans
gagnant n'a pas évolué aussi faire
annuler leurs plans de congés
ça sera un défi de commandement que là
on a des ce sont les gilet jaune
nicolas moreau et recel est-ce que selon
vous il faut oui ou non interdire cette
manifestation moi je vais ouais je vais
pas jouer mon libérale classique
je pense que c'est pas idiot de
l'interdire pour deux raisons d'abord si
on interdit ça fait office de coup de
semonce ce qui signifie qu'à partir du
moment où les gens se réunissent on a
déjà prévenu qu'il fallait pas le faire
et on est autorisé à
à réprimer la manifestation d'hier
convergence sous couvre-feu
non c'est pas la question en fait c'est
que s'il s'agit pas juste de dire c'est
ma liberté de me balader de manifester
avec le gilet jaune
il ya d'autres droits naturels qui
doivent être défendus notamment le droit
de propriété et quand ces gens ce qu en
ces gens se réunissent y créer les
conditions qui permettent ensuite des
saccages des vols des pillages de
magasins etc et on sait que ça va se
passer c'est pas assez pas à essayer de
le deviner
on sait que ça va se passer maintenant
le premier la première chose à faire
c'est de rétablir l'ordre
et ensuite si on l'interdît ça évite
aussi en quelque sorte qu'on joue à la
roulette russe avec avec le mouvement
c'est à dire que pourquoi on n'interdit
pas actuellement pour se donner bonne
image de libéral qui laisse les gens
manifester est pour et pour éviter
éviter un débordement et pour éviter
d'agacer les gilets jaunes qui veulent
manifester on sait que si on interdit la
manifestation et vont s'énerver
maintenant si on autorise la
manifestation et qu'il ya un quelconque
débordement et qui a un mort d'un côté
ou de l'autre ça va faire exploser la
situation de manière beaucoup plus
marquée que que l'agacement ne pas
pouvoir pas pouvoir manifester pareil
évidence il y en avoir il faut qu'ils
viennent pour [ __ ] le bazar
là aussi parce qu'il ya des gilet jaune
qui refusent de venir à paris sa au club
depuis l'arrivée du président ne faut
pas rigoler complètement raison
il ya deux raisons majeures pour
lesquelles c'est une faute politique
gravissime d'interdire la première
raison ça a été dit tout à l'heure par
monsieur macario sais que c'est
impossible c'est que c'est impossible et
que si le gouvernement interdit va se
retrouver dans la situation de la
commission européenne avec l'italie
c'est à dire de montrer à baisser le
pantalon simplement de montrer sa totale
totale inefficacité parce qu'il ne peut
pas matériellement empêcher les gens de
se réunir sur paris sauf un couvre-feu
enfin là on rentre autre chose et la
deuxième raison très simple ça a été dit
par monsieur trieurs il a tout à fait
raison c'est que il y a un début de
division du mouvement il ya les gilet
jaune libre et donc si vous si vous
interdisez vous empêcher cette fracture
là il ya des gens qui sont pas d'accord
parce que justement ça va déraper
je pense que dans l'intérêt tactique du
gouvernement moi je suis plutôt soutien
moral même si je suis effaré comme tout
le monde par les dégradations des biens
et attaquent aux biens et aux personnes
je suis content un soutien moral à ce
mouvement mais en tout cas je trouve que
il faut que
du point de vue du gouvernement ils
laissent ils les laissent manifester
alors reste une question centrale
l'ordre public ça c'est fondamental
c'est la première le premier des droits
de l'homme l'ordre public et la sûreté
d'abord les personnes enfin pardon
d'abord vous avez raison la propriété
mais avant la propriété la vie des
personnes il ya eu des pratiquement des
tentatives d'assassinats la dernière
fois et on sait qu'une toute une grande
joie des polars arrivé au pas seulement
il ya des gens qui sont rentrés dans des
cages d'immeubles et qui ont commencé à
menacer les familles donc là il ya
vraiment une colère terrible
une scène terrible c'est pas tout à fait
la même je pense ldj les jaunes d'un
côté et celle des entre guillemets
racaille de banlieue c'est pas tout à
fait la même qu'est ce qui va se passer
à mon avis il ne peut plus y avoir à ce
stade compte tenu des notamment des
moyens techniques disponibles qu'une
réquisition militaire à mon avis et
notamment pour sécuriser les bâtiments
notamment sur le plan statique et là on
risque en effet d'avoir des morts c'est
un risque mais enfin gouverner c'est
tuer c'est vraiment la base du
gouvernement de monopoliser la violence
et les monopoles de la race mais j'ai
bien évidemment c'est pour ça que les
policiers sont armés d'ailleurs une
remarque chiche là sur ce que vous
disiez sortir l'armée a appris que le
gouvernement voit le peuple comme
l'ennemi alors qu'ils n'ont c'est savoir
si les jets les jaunes sont ou non le
peuple
je voudrais que vous interrogez quelques
instants sur cette violence généralisée
qui touche même ceux qui ont rejoint le
mouvement récemment à savoir les lycéens
ecoutez jean michel blanquer a été ce
matin sur france info c'est bien sûr le
ministre de l'éducation nationale est il
lui même est effaré par le degré de
violence immédiat de ces manifestants
lycéens et ce qui est inquiétant c'est
pas le nombre qui reste faible
c'est qu'on est dans des formes
complètement différente de tout ce qu'on
a pu connaître par le passé avec une
violence que l'on a jamais vu alors que
le mouvement
vient d'arriver il est d'emblée
extrêmement violent comme dans les
médias une manifestation de samedi
dernier
il ya des gens qui n'ont plus de limites
nicolas moreau comment coup pour
expliquer cette que les limites soient
soit franchi dans la violence comme ça
ce qu'on peut les fraudes qui en ait
plus parce qu'on peut les franchir
impunément tout bêtement
il ya eu des manifestations assez
récente répression si vous voulez dire
exactement enfin que ce soit la
répression judiciaire ou policière
clairement on a beaucoup de monde en ce
moment que ce soit des lycéens ou que ce
soit plus spécialement des étudiants de
fac qui par exemple je pensais à tolbiac
où ils ont saccagé tolbiac ils ont ils
ont causé des millions de dégâts
ils ont causé des dégâts en dehors de
tolbiac et vraisemblablement et rebelote
tolbiac aujourd'hui dans quelque part
ils n'ont pas été dissuadés ils n'ont
pas été dissuadés de recommencer parce
que s'ils ont pas été demande de l'année
dernière de l'année dernière contre les
noël comme il ya deux ans enfin on a
bien vu il ya eu comme lui les blocages
en plus des universités l'année gardien
et ya plus de peur du gendarme donc par
an il centre à dissuader toute impunité
et un sentiment d'impunité et il n'y a
aucune condamnation morale des sortes à
venir il ya beaucoup de leaders de
gauche qui trouve ça très sympathique la
jeunesse par définition n'est ce pas
c'est l'innocence elle a tous les droits
c'est intolérable et si on signale au
sein de son gouvernement
j'ai critiqué tout à l'heure le miz
l'intérieur donc je vais essayer de
rétablir l'équilibré il ya un homme
ils m'ont profondément respectable et
animés de bonnes intentions c'est jean
michel blanquer
et quand il dit que la violence dépasse
tout ce qui a été imaginé il faut
l'écouter il a dit encore sur d'autres
médias les choses encore plus précises
sur ce 2ème violence et quand vous
écoutez les leaders du mouvement
étudiant
ils se hissent se mettent en grève sur
l'augmentation des droits qui s'applique
aux étudiants étrangers de la manière
qu'il y a quelques années ils étaient en
grève contre la réforme des retraites
pour des étudiants
donc tout le monde s'en souvient donc il
ya là un délire et il faut rappeler
l'ordre il ay rachid et chose je veux
dire la faculté n'est pas fait pour ça
et je pense qu'il ya effectivement un
énorme déficit d'autorité mais il vient
de tellement loin
il est tellement profondément enracinée
il englobe tellement la totalité du
paysage politique l'acheter à droite et
compassion intéressé à gauche que tout
ça est devenue inextricable
le résultat c'est que quand on est jeune
aujourd'hui quel est l'avenir qu'on a en
france
et quel avenir on se prépare c'est
hallucinant mis à part la notion sais
pas si vous ne partagez mais je trouve
que c'est le gilet jaune
il demande la limite ils demandent la
frontière ils demandent la protection il
demande l'autorité il demande l'état
partir et quand ils disent on a saccagé
notre économie c'est vrai il ya 165
emplois industriels chaque jour qui ont
disparu depuis 2001 ils demandent
simultanément la protection des
frontières contre les flux migratoires
et ils demandent le rétablissement de
l'ordre dans les banlieues a un ça va
c'est ça là ça va bien des boîtes à
montréal il sait pas c'est pas
l'autorité immédiate c'est pas les
symboles de la république qui sont
attaqués comme quand il ya des émeutes
de banlieues quand c'est pas ça c'est
pas cette autorité l'acquis et qui est
aujourd'hui attaquée l'autorité qui
attaquaient c'est l'autorité
institutionnelle de tous ceux qui sont
eux aux rênes aux commandes du pays que
ce soit la droite que ce soit la gauche
c'est la classe dirigeante ce sont les
élites ce sont les banquiers se sont
évidemment peut-être là la droite de
l'épreuve un joint lagos les professeurs
les enseignants et des médias tous ces
gens là pour ces invisibles de la
république sont à condamner et il ne
leur font plus confiance parce qu'ils
ont l'impression qu'ils ont pris en
otage le pays depuis des années et des
années
sur le plan financier sur le plan
intellectuel sur le plan moral et que in
en veulent plus ils veulent faire table
rase
on va parler d'un autre débat tout aussi
passionnés mais heureusement pas
d'autorité entre d'ailleurs absolument
est d'ailleurs déclaré c'est vraiment la
limite de leurs demandes au lit voilà
dès qu'il ya un leader qui émergent il
est menacé par les autres parlons d'un
sujet qui fait débat lui aussi mais de
façon d'être en plus calmes les
médicaments homéopathiques
il ya 1400